easy part of that question is that I'm
from Farmington Connecticut which is a
suburb outside of hartford when i was
growing up it was quite a small town
think ten or twelve thousand people it's
a lot bigger now but i grew up on a
pretty wooded street in a house fairly
far away from the neighbors and it was
somewhere in between a suburb in a you
know small country town kind of
existence i'm not sure how it made me
what I am today except that it was in
some ways kind of isolated and I had a
lot of time and so I read a lot and I
got started reading quite young on the
youngest of four kids and so I always
had a lot of books that my sisters and
my brother were reading and I kind of
picked up on that maybe pretty early
probably my oldest sister I want to read
a lot of science fiction and that meant
that I did too pretty much what I
remember is the science fiction from her
and my other sister Liz subscribe to all
these animal magazines like Ranger Rick
and international wildlife and all this
stuff so I would look at those even as a
pretty little kid and I always found
those quite entertaining but the science
fiction even there were like kids books
scifi books like a mad scientist club
and the enormous egg about this kid
who's chicken hatches of Triceratops egg
oh great books and I do remember those
from when i was when i was a kid quite a
lot
the two writers that I keep going back
to us as what other inspirations are
Flannery O'Connor and Langston Hughes as
writers of short stories which is kind
of interesting because I don't really
write short stories anymore but the two
of them have some just they both have a
remarkable control of language and they
write about stuff that's important to me
they write very generously Langston
especially it has just a huge heart and
that really comes through in his writing
and I turned to them pretty frequently I
read a lot of current stuff and I write
book reviews for a newspaper in Pakistan
so I read a fair amount of of new stuff
both from India and and from the states
you